5 von 5 werden mir zustimmen das hat sie
heute auch aufgeregt und zwar habe ich
mich heute sehr geärgert über die grünen
das ist nicht sonderlich verwunderlich
ich bin kein großer fan von ihnen schon
lange habe ich das gefühl dass die
wähler zur wahlurne gehen ja ein
bisschen wie das beten in der kirche mit
dem sc wie vor fahren die grünen wählen
fürs gewissen und jetzt gibt es auch
noch den richtigen song dafür
[Musik]
indem
wie schön unsere erde bahn das leben
wird das hier zu
kämpfen
und meine farm
anschluss an straße nur ziemlich eine
lachnummer sondern für mich ist vor
allem eine ohrfeige für jeden
wahlberechtigten in deutschland für wie
infantil halten die grünen uns
eigentlich was ist das bitte für ein
werbespot ich habe darüber nicht mehr
als gelacht beim ersten anblick sondern
wirklich angst gemacht mir wurde angst
und bange vor der welt die grünen für
uns auszeichnen wenn dieser bei
werbespot zeigen soll was die grünen für
unser land sind dann merkt man sie
werden den starken staat wollen der uns
alle wie kinderlein behandelt wo der
nette geistliche kommt und für uns denkt
also ich muss jetzt jedoch
widersprechen als ich diesen wahlkampf
sorgen mir angehört habe muss ich sagen
das ist doch etwas vom besten was die
grünen in diesem blog kaum zustande
gebracht haben und ich glaube das ist
auch kein blockiert weil einen so
schlechten sondern durch den harz opel
ist ja auch schon von jemandem geschenkt
worden ok
guten gehältern ist das schon verliert
nein ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn
ich das anschauen und sich die grünen
jetzt darauf konzentrieren würden in
deutschland solche songs zu schreiben
und stattdessen in der politik etwas er
von der bühne abtreten würden dann wären
das für mich eigentlich die wunsch
grünen großartig lasst sie liter
schreiben da machen sie nichts
schlimmeres das stimmt ich habe heute
auch gelesen bei social media viele
grünen-wähler oder mitten der
kommentiert das wird uns fünf prozent
kosten das wird uns drei prozent kosten
also selbst setzlingen sich in die
minderheit hinein sozusagen noch besser
ist übrigens mein anton hofreiter
auftritt weil das kostet jemand noch
mehr prozent also den wird eigentlich am
singen diesen song hab ich habe mir die
mühe gemacht und hab mir den text also
das original jedes mal angesehen und ich
finde es irgendwie es hat es planten
denn da heißt es in der dritten stufe
dass wir uns hier in diesem tal noch
treffen so viel hundert mal also das
heißt sie treffen sich im tal da haben
sie die umfrageergebnisse gut angucken
selbst wo die reise hingeht da muss man
braucht man viel unruhe um den song gut
zu finden und ich glaube dass die grünen
wirklich ich weiß gar nicht was das was
sind was die und räumt also erinnern uns
mal kurz
wo standen die denn eigentlich vor einem
halben jahr da hat man gedacht dann die
grünen werden die kanzlerin stellen da
hat man gedacht die anderen parteien
müssen sich nach ihnen richten dann
begann dieses bernburg unglück die
fehlentscheidung die falsche
kanzlerkandidaten zu nehmen statt den
haarweg zu nehmen jetzt singen sie
irgendwie lieder also zurzeit machen es
wirklich alle parteien ihren anhängern
schwer sie gut zu finden aber ich finde
den bevor wir uns jetzt hier so lustig
machen befürchte ich ja das dieses
schreckliche lied den jungen leuten
gefällt es glaube ich wirklich dass er
eine batterie heimat und sekten mehr
gemeinsamkeit also ich fürchte dass
dieses lied bei den jungen leuten bei
den jungen wellen sehr gut ankommen es
war auch gar nicht so willkürlich
ausgewählt als ich habe mich ja denn
heute ein bisschen mit dem lied
beschäftigt wenn man will ja nicht immer
nur waschen sondern erst mal die fakten
ansehen seid wirklich was damit zu tun
mit diesem heimatgefühl weil sie tun
hatten ja auch probleme in deutschland
dann sollte deutschland raus aus dem
namen also sie haben sich ja nicht
wirklich zu deutschland hingegeben hat
und ich glaube dieses lied selbst die
hoffnung der grünen
zurück zur heimat den deutschen zeigen
wir lieben deutschland
ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt ich habe in diesem
song das ist mir jetzt bewusst geboten
kommt eigentlich eine tiefe
kurskorrektur diesem jahr zum ausdruck
die eigentlich früher ja das wort
deutschland aus ihrem wahlprogramm raus
die praxen wollten und jetzt kommt
eigentlich die hinwendung zur heimat was
sie gehen die heimat noch ist nichts
gegen ein so etwas gemacht aber die
grünen haben sie gemäss sehr schwer
getan haben die haben sich das heißt das
ist ja eigentlich jetzt ein
intellektueller fortschritt für die
grünen das sich jetzt zu einem rock
heimat bekennen können muss ich muss das
muss das noch mal unterstreichen ist ein
genialer so denn sie dahin gelegt
werden
weil du ja ich muss zunächst
ich bin für schwarz-rot-gold da näher
als eine dann aber in einem land der
einsätze die lese ich gerne die zürcher
zeitung nennt also die hat schon gesagt
mensch macht doch teure bundeskoalition
und die ist eben schwarz rot gold sind
die grünen gar nicht dabei das sind die
kunden aber ich habe auch das sage ich
auch ganz klar wenn die gelben die ich
sehr schätze ich mache da wird hier
lindner und co da habe ich überhaupt
kein problem sagt er immer wieder sagen
besser kritisieren die regierenden sein
brief magath aber ganz schnell auf
wiedersehen hier nicht kokettieren mit
12 prozent dann müssten auch die wähler
nur sagen wir haben euch gewährt damit
ihre politik war ich kann ja und wenn
ihr grün wenn die dann ran kommen für
die schützen indirekt wenn ich bin ja
für schwarz gelb oder gold damit ist ja
nicht die große angst weil ich ja sehr
die spuren im saarland wenn ich dann
noch mal um drei doppel rheinland fans
dass ich direkt die vize
ministerpräsident oder der posten es von
einer grünen wenn ich dann runter gucke
nach hessen ist die andere seite
bouffier so der alte papst der cdu der
ist in der zweiten legislaturperiode mit
einem grünen wirtschaftsminister oder
stellvertretende ministerpräsident
fährst du nach stuttgart zu mercedes
dann meist trotz kretzschmar der ja seit
zehn jahren ministerpräsident ist laufen
die mercedes noch weiter fort also ich
bin jetzt mit ich hatte im nordrhein
westfalen war schnell fest ein alter
sagte die noch mit gegründet hat und wer
war auch stellen aber es war nicht so
schlimm wie wir das jetzt hier
darstellen wollen die vision aber wie
gesagt noch nicht jetzt keiner da
hinstellen sind auch jetzt mal wahlkampf
für die grünen aber das problem ist die
fdp ist besser als ein welches gefährt
nicht mehr mit einer tankstelle über
kritisieren schneller aber der deutsche
war kommt also auch hier nochmal diese
ferndiagnose von außen das ist schon
erschütternd was da zum teil einfach
auch nicht inhalt zutritt zum ausdruck
kommt ist man auch dieses lied wenn ich
dort das aus dem ironischen lustigen
rausnehmen und sage das ist sie
eigentlich fürchterlich wenn das
eigentlich jetzt das angebot ist das ist
unsere diskussion bedeutet was in berlin
rom gelangt ist bei den anderen parteien
nicht besser da sehe ich ein plakat der
fdp christian lindner da steht drauf
noch nie gab es mehr zu tun er steht mit
dem man muss ja im
klassement knapp drüber fragt also nach
45 in deutschland
ist das zweite lindner ist nun die
schweiz gekommen wollen diese woche in
die schweiz machte wahlkampf für die
gefühl millionen deutschen die in der
schweiz sind und dort abstimmen können
quasi wie ein erdogan in deutschland
kommt ländern in die schweiz und die
deutschen machen
ist vielleicht gerade unter deutschen
wahlkampf technik im ausland wo kaufe
ich mache das wird er ja bei apple gar
nicht gut wenn man freunde wir haben wir
sprechen über die grünen und magister
lindner das hat er nicht verdient also
das hat das hat man dagegen nicht
verdient mir ging noch ein bisschen kopf
durch den begriff heimat wenn ich das
richtig sehe ist es ja auch ein
volkslied also das heißt die grünen
haben jetzt die heimat entdeckt und das
volk das wird auch nicht spurlos
sozusagen an der innerparteilichen
diskussion
vorbeigehen wollte was das kannst du mir
was hat da geritten sowas zu machen es
ist wirklich dieses wie wir es auch eben
analysiert haben es ist der rückgang zur
heimat es ist ein korrektur welche die
haben gemerkt ok uns gehen die stimmen
flöten und patricia was dann abgestimmt
heisst flöten gegangen mobil.de aber bei
der jugend und ich habe ja heute hab ich
habe mir wirklich angetan die zwei
stunden lang jegliche kommentare zu
diesen dingen bei den grünen auf den
seiten der grünen gelesen und die jungen
schreiben auch wirklich es berührt mich
ich weine beim anblick ihr habt mein
herz getroffen es rührt mich zu tränen
und ich glaube dieser schachzug den vor
allem auch den jungen die heimat zu
präsentieren heimatgefühle zu wecken
danach sehnen sich aktuell auf viele
deutschen dass sie nicht erkennen dass
die grünen bevormundung für uns wollen
auch dieser werbespot völlig infantil
ist ich empfinde ihn als ohrfeige ich
glaube die
wahlberechtigte ist subtil das ist ganz
gefährlich was wir machen weil er wird
funktionieren
er wird funktionieren weil sich weil sie
junge leute total orientierungslos sind
die jetzt auch in der korona zeit sie
können nicht richtig ausgehen sie könne
nicht verreisen
die kneipen sind zu ja und da irgendwie
finden sie sich um also ja sowie wände
sowieso wandergesellen und gemeinsam
werden sie aus wangen mit der laute und
und und sich und sich wohl ja aber es
ist anders die jungen wollen nicht mehr
an ecken ich glaub ich sehe das ganz
große problem ist nicht mehr en vogue
anecken ist eigentlich blöd und möchte
so genau genau jene und das hasse ich
aber so sehr an den grün- und an diesem
werbespot die persönliche freiheit ist
so ein wichtiges gut demokratien sind
nein sager gesellschaften diktaturen
sind ja sager gesellschaft und ich denke
mir bei diesem anblick sollen wir alle
eine masse sein also immer das
individuum dahinter
[Musik]